Question, what is the best multiple vitamin? Well, there's a lot of multiple vitamins on the market. Your
key things that you should look at with vitamins themselves is how do you know the quality?
How are you supposed to know the quality? It's kind of pretty fancy label and it looks nice and
the drug has said it's a great supplement who says. So,
understand there's a difference in supplements between synthetic portions of supplements. I do believe
that there's a use for those and a whole food supplement. So the difference in that is a whole
food supplement is made just basically from the food itself and so like a greens drink would be
a whole food supplement. There's not a whole lot of whole food multiple on the market.
We do have one. We actually have a private label that has a free data but it is a whole food
supplement. It's really the only whole food supplement that we have as far as a multi vitamin.
Besides the different like greens first products that are out there. So a lot of our patients will
use greens first. They come in capsules and that comes in a powder that you can mix as you know a
smoothie or something like that. So those are always the best. The whole food product is always the
best as far as a multiple goals. All the other supplements that are out there you have to be careful
careful with as a multiple because most of them are synthetic and especially the synthetic bees and
some of the other synthetic vitamins. You don't absorb well. Your body doesn't use well. So you have to
be careful with that. So I'm not a big fan of just finding a multiple and taking a multiple
thinking that you've solved your problems but also because they're not tailored to what you have
going on. Remember I just said that people with cancer have to be careful of things that they
be somebody with just part disease and they don't have a history of cancer. Somebody with cancer
should not be taking the multiple that has copper. Most multiples out there because they're using
the synthetic supplements. They don't care about how their minerals are key-laden. So I'll talk about
that in just a second. So it's really improperly key-laden minerals which are garbage and can actually
be harmful for you. Maybe have iodide in it which I got big fan of iodide because the
issue with thyroid issues iodide is made cause of Hashimoto's and Graves disease.
And most of them have a very poor source of folate as folic acid and no human
meat should consume folic acid. Folic acid is a synthetic folate and it has been hypothesized
that folic acid, the synthetic folate is what has caused defects in a gene called the MTHRG
and that leads to issues with that person's ability to even process natural folate that you
could get in your foods and that is an issue in our society. So there's a lot of garbage,
some of them out there that nobody should be taking. So many times when people come in and they're
taking the supplement and it's like sorry you might have we just throw this away. This is just
this is not good for you to give to your human or a dog or anything. They're not good for anybody to
consume. So when you look at a supplement, you know your key things that you look at are
if I could think you look at the folic acid, is it folate as methyl tetrahedral folate?
L that's it's MTHL tetrahedral folate? Well then that's a good folate but again it gets more
technical because somebody with cancer shouldn't be taking that. So is the B12
sciatocamolomy? Nobody should be taking that throw it away. Is it methyl comolomy? Well a cancer
patient shouldn't be taking that. Is it a dentistocamolomy? That her broxy comolomy? Yeah that's
good for comolomy. You know that they cared about that supplement. Is are the minerals
chelated correctly? What's the calcium? Is it calcium carbonate? If there's calcium,
if there's any of these are red flags for me? Oh it's calcium carbonate. They didn't care about how
what they put in that supplement then. So understand any supplement paint let's let's sell supplements.
We can make a lot of money selling supplements. Let's make a multiple. Well what should we do? Let's
put the best stuff in there. Oh that's too expensive. Let's just put this other joke in there. We can
make a whole lot more money. Okay let's do that. I'm sorry but that's exactly what takes place
in a lot of these companies. A lot of the supplement companies have been purchased by drug companies
and they don't necessarily have your best interest in money. So I can look at a back of a supplement
model to tell you whether you should take it or not by looking at these key things. Doesn't that fall
look acid? Just throw it away. Is the calcium calcium carbonate throw the thing away? Is the B12
cyanocabolubite throw the thing away? If you have cancer then you have to look out for other things
that you should not be taking. So minerals should be chelated with a double bond to an amino acid.
There's only two companies in the world that do that. It's called tracks and let me think of the
other one. But they don't sell their own supplements. They sell to good supplement companies. So if
it says tracks or all beyond, all beyond that's the other day. Then you know it's a good mineral
key later there. If it isn't to tracks or to all beyond mineral then it's probably not double bond
into an amino acid and you shouldn't be taking it. You take calcium carbonate. It's like you need
limestone. Okay you're not supposed to eat limestone. We're not supposed to eat trace minerals that
are not bonded double bond to an amino acid. Trace minerals are what are in the soil. Soil-based
minerals that are taken by a plant and converted and bonded to a double bond amino acid and then we eat
plants or we eat animals that ate plants. So that's how you get your minerals. You don't get your
minerals by eat dirt. So a lot of the minerals that are in these poorly formulated mineral supplements
and multibiterals and multivitamins are just the cheapest soil-based minerals which are that
they're not good human consumption. You do absorb those are the things that damage your gut. If you do
absorb them they don't get into cells to function as calcium or magnesium or selenium. They end up
getting deposited ligamentus insertion sites. They get deposited at joint capsules. They conform
degenerative arthorides and cause blood issues. They can get bonded to places that they should bond
to. They can damage arteries. They're just not good things. So you're better off not taking any
supplements. You're better off getting them from your food if you possibly can. If you want to
supplement that's the whole idea of a supplement. You're supplementing your diet. You want to get
it in a whole food form as possible and you have to know a little bit about supplements to make sure
you're not getting bad bruises or the divine garbage. So yeah so the best multiple I would say
would be a whole food greens product something like that or we have one that's actually labeled
prenatal complete but it's a good whole food supplement but it's not for
cancellation. The president does have to cooperate.